[Musique]
à la pompe les prix ne cessent de
grimper au point où les automobilistes
sont eux mêmes surpris à chaque plan le
sans plomb a d'ailleurs battu hier un
nouveau record 1 euros 78 en moyenne
tout comme le gazole 1 euros 65 là il ya
une flambée des prix blocs orly prix
nous on pense que il faut aller chercher
récupérer l'argent plutôt sur les marges
des distributeurs des producteurs type
total et autres j'ai donc demandé au
ministre de l'économie et des finances
de modifier dès cette semaine l'arrêté
définissant le barème kilométrique il
sera réhaussé de 10% il ya très peu de
mesures qui ont un impact substantiel
sur quelque chose qui ne dépend pas de
nous en l'espèce sont les cours ils sont
les cours mondiaux et donc accompagner
nos compatriotes de la manière la plus
efficace c'est de faire ce qu'on a fait
bémol la mesure concerne uniquement ceux
qui payent l'impôt sur le revenu - d'un
foyer sur deux et ceux qui ont opté pour
le forfait réel plutôt que l'abattement
forfaitaire de 10% total deux millions
et demi de contribuables a priori c'est
l'une des maisons de retraite les plus
luxueuses de france la résidence des
bords de seine à neuilly un ehpad orpea
où le loyer coûte de 6500 euros à 12000
euros par mois pour la chambre la plus
haut de gamme dans un livre enquête le
journaliste indépendant ha castanet
décrit un système atroce au sein du
groupe d'ehpad privées orpea on n'avait
pas de stock les soignants devait se
débrouiller mais comme elle pouvait
c'était des serviettes de bain c'était
voilà dans les pattes je répète le plus
luxueux de front les soins d'hygiène la
prise en charge médicale voire les
et pardon hop je suis complètement
perdue les retards les repas absolument
voilà tout cela serait rationner pour
améliorer la rentabilité j'ai une aide
soignante il me raconte comment même à
orpéa bord de seine dans cet
établissement de luxe elle rationnel le
nombre de biscottes qu'elle donnait
chaque jour à ses résidents et quand
c'était deux biscottes s'était pas 3
demandé à la ministre déléguée en charge
et l'autonomie brigitte bourguignon de
saisir immédiatement le groupe de
manière à ce que des réponses puisse
être apportée nous le devons notamment
familles et aux résidents et aux
soignants le directeur avec qui je
m'entendais très bien intimant embauché
au mois d'août m'a convoqué et m'a dit
laurange par facture est on n'arrivera à
rien il avait raison il faut remettre
des indicateurs de qualité de soins dans
les ehpad et il faut les rendre
publiques et je pense que en rendant
publiques ses indicateurs eh bien on
permettra j'allais dire à la société de2
de juges et de comment nos aînés sont
traités nous sommes choqués cela ne
correspond pas à nos valeurs
cela ne correspond pas à notre
engagement je suis allé en bretagne à
brest je fais la normandie je suis allé
dans l'aisne et à chaque fois j'ai
rencontré des familles et des membres du
personnel qui me racontait les mêmes
dysfonctionnements il ya des accusations
nous ne prétendons pas être parfait nous
ne prétendons pas ne jamais nous tromper
ce que nous prétendons c'est d'être très
éloigné de ce qu'on veut nous faire
porter en terme d'image en termes de
volonté et les résultats voyez-vous sont
au rendez vous de nos espérances ses
1400 % de condamnations en plus et puis
nous confisque ont chaque fois que nous
le pouvons ses véhicules
[Musique]
il paraît qu'un bon chef c'est celui qui
sait bien s'entourer
la
[Rires]
gouverner avec des communistes c'est pas
dur pour moi les verts c'est un peu plus
compliqué mais on fait des jolis
mouvements vers nous je trouve on était
contents on ne servent à rien